hello everyone and welcome back to
another really awesome game from round
six of the feeder candidates tournament
2022 it's hikaru nakamura versus dingle
and it is uh well as you might uh might
expect a very very complicated game that
will uh will just be very very enjoyable
for you i believe but before we check
out the actual game i would just like to
mention uh if by any chance you run into
boris girlfriend uh today in a you know
in a bar or in a library or wherever uh
do uh not forget to uh wish him a very
happy birthday so just uh just saying
you know uh uh
in case you run into him you never know
uh but now getting back to the game uh
nakamura opens with ponte e4 and the
ding replies with e5 we have knight to
f3 knight to c6 and bishop to c4
and the dean goes for knight to f6 the
two knights defense of course he's
avoiding the evan's gambit he's uh you
know not going into that so knight f6
with d3 and bishop to c5 going into the
joko pianissimo variation
c3 and now pawn to d6 we have castles by
both players uh and here he color goes
rook to e1 the hikaru goes rook to e1
and this has been played so many times
that we are not going to even discuss
the moves uh we have a5 stopping b4 from
white which is always a good idea uh
h3h6 and knight beat to d2 we have
bishop to e6 attacking the bishop and
the bishop to b5 we have queen to b8 uh
going for the standard idea of shifting
the queen over to a7 and then you're
going to put a
incredible pressure on this diagonal and
now a knight to f1 is the most popular
here but we have an instant trade the
bishop captures b captures and now pawn
to d4 attacking the bishop captures
captures and bishop back to b6 and here
pawn to a4 so again nothing new here
rook to e8 and rook to a3 now later on
when the knight moves you can easily
shift the rook into the attack and there
is a game uh very very uh
uh well known one from 2017 anishigiri
had it against david
where uh
david anton played queen to b7 anish was
able to win that game but here ding
plays queen to a7 and it is now as of
move 15 that we have a completely new
game
and now uh what is uh what can hikaru do
here so he there's a lot of pressure on
this diagonal obviously you can't just
push some pawns uh you're going to lose
the f2 pawn so knights to f1
we have d5 by ding and now pawn to e5
you allow hikaru to grab more space in
the center but you also win the e4
square for your pieces so knight's the
e4 now he carved attacks the knight
knight one to d2 and the bishop to f5 we
have rook to e2 adding another defender
to the f2 pawn and here we have rook 8
d8 if you're wondering about this pawn
whether we could capture it or not of
course you you cannot uh if you capture
it then we just captured the knight and
now you're you're just down a piece it
doesn't really matter what you play d
captures an e4 attacks the night we
simply capture with the knight to nag
the bishop and that's it we play bishop
b3 uh we are up a full night so that's
out of the question so rook a to d8 ding
just continues development and now
knight to b3 the d4 pawn is nicely
defended uh but ding says
you know what you have a very strong
center but i have a double c pawn and i
i don't need a you know a double pawn so
i'm just going to advance one of them at
the mess up your pawn structure here and
it is of course the absolute best move
hikaru has to capture we have bishop
captures knight captures and queen
captures on c5 still putting a really
just a lot of pressure here on this f2
square uh knight to d4 attacking the
bishop and the bishop back to d7 nicely
controlling the knight on the e4
bishop to f4 just continuing development
you have to develop this bishop
somewhere and now queen back to e7
and uh what can hikaru do here he goes
for knight to b5 the very interesting
pawn push with pawn to e6 is uh that's
all that it is it's just very
interesting the point is if you capture
with the bishop okay we can win some
material here but if you capture with
the pawn uh there's just uh not a good
continuation for hikaru he can simply
start trading bishop captures on c7
bishop captures an a4 queen captures
queen captures we're going to capture on
a5 and you get this position uh where
it's equal material he car would have a
pass b pawn being a past d-pawn but
you know it's nothing really so instead
hikaru goes for knight to b5 uh and ding
captures it if you could play c5 that
would be very nice you would have a lot
of presence in the center but the
problem is uh here hikaru can just go
for this annoying rook captures an e4
idea d captures knight to d6 and this
knight is not just a monster here hikaru
uh is putting all of this pressure look
at the bishop look at the knight the
rook is coming to g3 the queen is coming
to h5 i i mean it's just an incredible
position uh for yes for for an exchange
sacrifice but the knight on d6 is a
monster it's on a dark square a ding ha
only has a light square bishop he's not
going to be able to
uh move it from there it's uh this
knight is stronger than all of these
pieces combined so of course he's not
gonna allow this thing eliminates the
knight a bishop captures on b5 a
captures and now knight to g5
re-maneuvering the knight over to
uh e6 and while you could maybe trade
and and grab the a5 pawn uh it it it's
really nothing captures on a5 a link
just captures an e5 or he starts pushing
d4 so again nothing really to worry
about here so here hikaru tries grabbing
the a5 phone right away and now it's
updating to prove that uh well this uh
he's down upon so can he play this so
knights the e6 attacking the bishop here
bishop back to d2 and now pawn to d4
ding starts pushing his pass pawn
rook to a3 he car wants to remaneuver
this rook back into the attack and now
queen the c5 uh going after the b5 pawn
and later on maybe even the b2 pawn we
have rooked the g3 by hikaru now putting
pressure on that king as bishop captures
an h6 is now always an idea but to just
pawn to d3 attacking the rook here rook
to e1 and now dink captures the pawn we
have queen captures on v5 and now the
question is can you capture an h6 right
away and should you if you can well not
really if you capture on h6 right now
then d2 wins the game for ding but it's
not
all that all that clear why for example
rook to e3 king to f8 and now what do
you play now we are threatening to win
the bishop here so uh where do you move
the bishop that's uh that's the question
uh and if you try harassing the queen
for example something like this we can
even give up the queen or rather give up
the queen for two rooks and the position
is uh well just winning for black you
if you grab the pawn which you can for
the moment then we double up here and
even if you deliver this check to save
your bishop c5 ensures that you don't
save the bishop you're gonna have to
give it up and now it's a queen against
two rooks and the knight this would of
course be winning footing so a premature
bishop captures on h6 is not the way to
go he carl plays queen to h5 just brings
another attacker into the game and now
uh ding goes for queen captures on b2 uh
he grabs the pawn allows the bishop
captures on h6 and now what do you play
here that is the question uh ding played
d2 which is basically
uh which is basically uh forcing a draw
and ending the game queen to b4 on the
other hand uh seemingly allows the ding
to continue the the game uh because now
you are threatening to capture the rook
here hikaru has to deal with this and
then you play queen to e4 and now you
brought the queen back to the king side
now the the queen can also help out with
the defensive bishop to e3 uh we're
gonna play g6 and the game continues
with uh ding always probably being a
little bit better he can start pushing
the past c pawn uh with perfect play
it's nothing but um you know maybe
better than than what the ding decided
to do d2 was played and now he car plays
rook to d1 now a lot of pressure is
being put on this uh d2 pawn also if the
queen goes back we can just capture it
and now uh ding just goes for rook to d5
point is if queen to c2 which okay is
very annoying you can help out with the
defense also you're putting pressure on
this d1 rook after queen e2 we're going
to win this pawn for example f5 we're
just going to capture it rook captures
on d2 we trade everything captures
captures captures captures and captures
and now rook d8 attacks the bishop
bishop g5 let's say rook to d4 it's uh
it's a nice position for both of them
but you know not much to look forward to
so instead rook to d5 by ding and now
hikaru has to decide the e5 pawn is
being threatened and there is uh pretty
much only only one good move that he can
do here f4 is a bit too ambitious uh he
doesn't want to try this so he just goes
for bishop captures on g7 and now ding
does not have a choice he has to accept
this and it is basically a forced draw
not basically it is a force draw so real
captures on g7 king captures and queen
to g5 check controlling all of the dark
squares here which ensures the draw king
f8 we have queen to hit czech king the
g8 queen g5 chair king to f8 queen to h6
check and now ding even tries king to a7
but queen back to f6 now forcing the
king to f8 because even though you can
go to d7 and it's still a draw uh you
have to allow queen captures on f7 which
wins back one of the rooks after the
king moves we're gonna win this one with
checking b7 now king h2 and now hikaru
is just up two pawns even okay with with
perfect place still a draw but why would
you why would you do this so king back
to a fate queen h6 king to g8 and he was
in this position that the players agree
to a draw it's move 42 so time control
has been reached nothing to worry about
but there is uh of course nothing more
to be done here hikaru is down the rook
so there is nothing for hikaru to try uh
he has to
hold hold the draw so really really a
wonderful game hikaru uh did uh
surprising in the opening had to spend a
little bit of time there's even a nice
photo there you can see uh hikaru just
blitzing out his moose and being you
know deep in thought not maybe not
maybe it's not that he doesn't like his
position but he has to uh recall what he
knows about uh this joke opinissimo that
you know everyone plays it's such an
annoying opening uh but yeah hikaru just
enjoying the game between
rapport as you guys probably have if
you've seen the previous video if you
haven't do check it out and enjoy it
like hikaru was in the photo uh so yeah
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it uh very nice draw between hikaru and
the ding and for those of you who want
me to show the standings uh after every
game here are the standings so after six
rounds uh yanni ponchi is leading with
four and a half points then fabi with
four points in second place uh nakamura
and rapport tied uh with with three
points then with two and a half points
at a job with england and youngshish of
duda and uh currently in last place uh
alireza firuja with two points so there
we have it uh tomorrow is the
seventh round today we don't have any
runs yesterday's the rest day tomorrow
uh the leader yanni pony she faces
and if he can manage
a draw there or even win he's probably
you know going as the leader in the
second part of the tournament as
tomorrow will be the end of the first
half of the candidates and then everyone
just plays everyone again only with
different uh pieces color
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
derek
vocal hayden ago fabi uh dermot and
fergus from david vikas sony ryan urban
and hans anderson for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to cover the candidates until
it finishes so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day